[Music]  [Applause]  explain  this is where we take videos of famous  people and we combine them usually for  no good reason that's right  first up we've melded karl rove and  james franco  [Applause]  i love it it puts my energy in a  different direction i i get to look at  other people's work and  not think about myself for you know a  few hours every day yeah  next up pat robertson and marilyn manson  it's not a pleasant situation  but this is what the bible talks about  when it says you can't by yourself  and finally avril lavigne and sylvester  stallone  [Music]  [Applause]  it's a freak of nature i have no idea  how it happened and i don't claim  authorship to in that sense it's just  one of those minor miracles in my life  [Applause]